hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the axolotl salamander is
a model of nerve dependent regeneration
presented by Johanna Vargas she is a
post doctoral biologist at Northeastern
University
I am Marjory tourist of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational lab seminar presented by lab
Reed's lab reeds is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located on the
lower left of the presentation window
and tech your questions into the box
that appears on the screen will answer
as many questions do we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credit please click on the
button on the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
John Hannah Farkas I will now turn the
presentation over to her
hello everybody and thank you so much
for watching my presentation today I'm
Johanna and I'm really excited to talk
to you about the work that we do at
Northeastern University on this amazing
animal called the axolotl salamander and
I'll be talking to you today about the
salamanders ability to regenerate and
the ways in which we're studying this
ability in order to hopefully unlock the
ability to regenerate and other less
regenerative animals now when I say for
generation today regeneration is a word
that has a lot of different definitions
depending on who you ask and in what
context you ask
I'd like to define her generation before
we get started today so that we're all
on the same page and today regeneration
I will define as the return of a missing
structure so the example I'll be using
today is the amputation of a salamander
limb which is then capable of
regenerating back to a fully functional
limb which looks identical to the
amputated original and this is an area
of study and has become increasingly
popular and increasingly well funded
because it has so many promising
possibilities so for example this is a
an advertisement from the American Heart
Association promoting the study of the
zebrafish which is capable of
regenerating parts of its heart after
they have been transected and so we want
to study this complete functional
regeneration in animals that are capable
of it
in order to hopefully utilize their
abilities in other animals such as
ourselves and the animal that I'll be
talking to you about today is the
Mexican axolotl which us axolotl
researchers like to refer to as the
champion of regeneration might be a
little self-indulgent but these are
really amazing animal models and I have
here pictures of three different kinds
of axolotls so these are all the same
species but they have different colors
different pigments on the right you'll
see that pigmented animal is a wild type
looks just like they're found in the
wild in the middle is an albino animal
that animal does not have any pigment
just a spectrum an albino and on the
left is what we call a leucistic or
white animal and these animals have
pigment in their embryos they have
pigmented eyes but they are overall
white so we're able to actually see
through them and
active tissue grafts as well and these
are the sorts of animals that I'll be
using throughout the presentation those
leucistic ones now today I'll be
discussing the regeneration of the
axolotl limb
again if you amputate that limb it grows
back fully you would never know it had
even been amputated but these animals
have a vast array of other abilities
that are really just incredible to
witness and study so for example they
can regenerate transected spinal cords
they can regenerate their gills if those
gills are cut off they can regenerate
their retinas their jaws a number of
internal organs are saying it's sort of
what doesn't kill them will just grow
back and while I'll be focusing on the
limb today I just want to talk a little
bit about how these animals have such an
amazing array of regenerative abilities
they're just a really incredible model
for this process particularly as you'll
see in the next slide because they're a
little bit unique in the animal kingdom
I don't want to make it sound like that
excellence allamanda is the only animal
that is capable of her generation
there's actually a really surprising
array of animals that can do so however
they are somewhat more complex in terms
of tissue and structure than many of the
other regenerative animals that we study
so I have here an array of animals that
are capable of tissue regeneration
ranging from the Hydra at the top in the
middle there to frog tadpoles so adult
frogs can't regenerate very well but
tadpoles can as well as zebrafish
starfish I'm a bottom left is a flat
worm called a planarian and crustacean
not as an ostracod is in the bottom
middle there now when I hope you can
appreciate in the slide is that the
axolotl stands apart from these other
animals because it's a little bit more
similar to us the X level is a tetrapod
meaning it has four limbs much like we
do and it's also capable of regenerating
more complex levels of tissue compared
to a fish fin ray which is not quite as
complexity only amputated limb now as
you probably are aware mammals are not
particularly good for generators but
there is one type of mammal one genus of
mouse called the African spiny mouse or
Kony's which is capable of complex
tissue regeneration so these my section
of this incredible
adaptation where if a Predator grabs
them from the back the back skin will
actually fall off slough off and then it
will regenerate fully up to and
including the hair follicles which is
something we as humans are not doing so
while regeneration is very rare in
mammals it is present in a small portion
of mice and study is ongoing to see how
these might resemble salamanders and I
will note that these mice are still very
recently been discovered and are still
being studied for this ability now limb
regeneration in the Mexican axolotl is a
very reliable process by which by that I
mean it proceeds in a number of steps
that we can really well characterize the
timing of this regeneration is going to
vary depending on the size and age of
the animal but it always precedes in the
following fashion first of all the limb
is amputated and the wound heals over
and this wound healing occurs incredibly
rapidly compared to what we would expect
from our wounds so we have the
theorization just the covering of the
wound site occurs within 24 hours after
the amputation is completed after the
wound has healed what forms next is
called a blastema that's the little bump
that you can see at the end of the limb
there the blastema
is a collection basically a bag of
proliferating cells that forms from a
number of different cell types
this can include fibroblasts of
connective tissue and schwann cells
which surround the nerves
it can include satellite cells to other
muscles and basically all these cells go
back in time a little bit and become
like precursor cells which then form is
regenerating blastema and grow outward
and as that blastema grows eventually
the digits start to form and over time
typically we could say about 30 days but
again this varies a lot depending on the
size of the animal we see
differentiation of original tissue types
the formation of digits and the
conclusion of her generation which
results in a limb that is functionally
identical to the original one now today
I'm going to be focusing mostly on this
blastema formation and growth portion of
regeneration because this is something
that kind of sets axels apart from
humans right we don't see blastemas
generally speak
and it's also a big mystery we want to
know how does this proliferating mass of
cells form how is it told to continue to
proliferate and how does it eventually
form a new limb so I would like you to
take away from this slide is simply the
blastema definition as this idea of a
perforating mass cells then one really
curious and fascinating if you ask me
characteristic of axolotl regeneration
is called nerve dependency and this is a
phenomenon that was first observed by
Tweedy John Todd who x-square was a real
person Victorian novel protagonist it
was first discovered by him in 1823 this
is a very old research question and the
axolotl itself is a very old animal
model having been studied since the 16
and 1700s what 20 John Todd found is
that if he intercepted the sciatic nerve
this is the nerve that leads into the
hind limbs he found that regeneration
didn't take place in many cases the limb
did not regenerate at all and some it
actually deteriorated to the point that
it actually essentially ended up back at
the animals body cavity so this was a
really big question you know why if he
got rid of these nerves and I'll show
you how we do this in just a moment why
did this completely prevent regeneration
this is a topic that has fascinated us
as biologists for nearly two centuries
now and this is how we dinner bait so
this is a bit more extreme of a surgery
this is simply opened up to show where
those nerves are but you'll see with the
arrows the one two and three are the
three major nerves that pin through the
brachial plexus just found right about
here in humans and innervate that limb
so they start the spinal cord and they
innervate all the way down that limb
what we can do is actually do a very
small incision and find these nerves and
just sever them so we grab them with
forceps and we just cut them this means
that we're not removing the nerve from
the lamb we're simply cutting it and
this process completely prevents
regeneration so long as we cut at least
two of those three brachial plexus
peripheral nerves now a normal
regenerating limb
looks like this you can see the blastema
is that little triangle at the end of
the limb that's around 11 days post
amputation that's what DPA is going to
stand for throughout this presentation
but
we D Nevada limit the day of amputation
if we cut those nerves at the brachial
plexus what we see is a limb that has
completely failed to proliferate or form
a blast even the wound heals over just
fine but nothing happens after that and
in fact you'll see some blood at the tip
indicating that there's something going
on at the surface that maybe isn't usual
so we can really say is that denervation
cutting the nerves leading into the limb
prevents limb regeneration at a very
early step right so it prevents it
essentially right after the wound has
healed after that nothing will happen
and a limb will not regenerate until
those nerves come back in which they do
because the x100 generates everything
now here's an image of a blastema an
innovative blastema and I hope you can
see that really lovely bundle of
proliferating cells at the end there
it's very dense all those cells look
pretty modernist different tissue types
but the date available in looks quite a
bit different so you may be able to see
that this limb is essentially falling
apart there's a lot of osteoclasts in
there which are those big cells with
multiple nuclei and the limit self is
simply not proliferating at all in fact
this limb is regressing and undergoing
tissue analysis instead this is a very
drastic process that completely halts
her generation in his tracks for long
lengths of time this is an immunity to
chemical stain showing how intimately
nerves contact that growing limb early
on the process this is Dave 6 BPA or
days post amputation and the nerves are
stained in red and you can see that that
nerve is innervating that growing
blastema very very closely so it's going
straight into the wound site it's
heading into the epidermis and a lot of
proliferating cells which are stained
and green that's a beer to you a
pre-recorded marker there's a lot of
proliferative cells sort of around that
nerve which indicates to us that the
nerve might have some sort of role in
supporting proliferation now if this was
a salamander specific phenomenon it
would still be really interesting and we
still want to study it but it might not
be quite so relevant to other modes of
Health study happily this is a
phenomenon that's actually nearly
ubiquitous in regenerating vertebrates
and in some invertebrates as well
regeneration of the Frog tadpole which I
mentioned earlier is nerve dependence as
is regeneration of for example that
catfish barbell even starfish limbs do
not regenerate if that oral nerve ring
in the center is damaged and we've seen
this phenomenon and many other as well
now as I said earlier I guess you
probably already know humans aren't
great regenerators but that doesn't mean
the nerve dependence isn't relevant
towards our health in fact it's a very
important question and this is because
nerve dependence is observed during
human wound healing as an example
paraplegic patients actually undergo
impaired wound closure in wounds that
occur in regions which are not well
innervated or innervated also peripheral
neuropathy during diabetes can lead to
what are known as diabetic ulcers so
what happens here are the peripheral
nerves are damaged in the extremities
such as the hands or feet and when that
extremity is injured there is no nerve
present to support the healing of that
wound
thus the wound instead of heeling over
ulcerates and becomes much more
complicated from a health standpoint and
I have not included a picture of a
diabetic ulcer because I don't know how
many of you are eating right now so what
I'd like to take away from this
introduction is that without an intact
nerve supply regeneration cannot take
place I'm going to say usually here
because I'm about to show you some
experimental exceptions now like I said
this is a question that has persisted
for almost two centuries and it has been
the source of study for quite quite a
few scientists especially in the past
100 years one of these scientists was
Marcus Singer conducted a lot of really
beautiful experiments in the mid 20th
century and eventually came up with what
he calls the neuron trophic hypothesis
the neuro trophic hypothesis states that
nerve supply the regenerating lamb with
a proliferative factor by which I mean
the nerve synthesize some sort of
protein that is then released at the
wound site and then promotes
proliferation so it's believed that this
vector is synthesized up at the dorsal
root ganglia which are the cell bodies
of the nerves that are integrating the
limb then from there it travels down the
limb and is released at the blood
to support regeneration so this
neurotrophic hypothesis has been very
well supported but the question of what
exactly the spectre or what these
factors are has fascinated scientists
for decades now and it's a question that
still doesn't have a really clear answer
our goal for today or our goal for the
previous research as well my goal for
today is to show you the research that
we've done on this topic and we wanted
to look at the possible identification
of these factors and we believe just
that we should start in a really simple
place we should just find a factor that
demonstrates three very very basic
characteristics first of all it should
be found in the correct places the
peripheral nerves and the dorsal root
ganglia right because any factor this
supplied by the nerves should be found
in those cell bodies and should also be
found in the nerves and that decided
amputation the factors should be capable
of rescuing regeneration and Dean abated
limbs by which I mean we should be able
to supply a döner vated lab with this
vector that should be able to grow at
least a little bit even in the absence
of nerves and inhibition of this vector
should be capable of blocking
regeneration even in fully innovated
otherwise normal animals and we decided
to focus on a protein called nerve
regulan one which was a promising
candidate because previous studies have
been shown that it is upregulated after
amputation and that it may have to do
with blasting or proliferation and
growth now I have a very fancy animation
here show you how everything works okay
maybe not that fancy but the point is
that nary gun one is a lag and that's
extracellular it binds to a receptor
called rp3 and then it repeat three
heterodimer eise's with a receptor
called fe 2 which phosphorylates a
number of downstream signals and these
signals have been found to be implicated
in cell proliferation cell survival and
cell migration so you can see why it
might be a really good candidate factor
for looking at factors that promote less
stable proliferation and there's a lot
more I can talk about in terms of how
this leg and this protein works but what
I'd like you to take away from this is
that the regulan Wan is very promising
candidate and it's active receptor is
called herb b2 I'll be talking about
those quite a bit in the upcoming slides
and our question has upset was very
simple doesna regulan one fulfill the
three criteria that I described earlier
and this work has been very recently
published and first of all we simply had
to look for it to this end we collected
tissues in this case at dorsal root
ganglion again those cell bodies of the
at the entrance of the limb and we
sectioned and stain them for in a
regulan one using immunohistochemical
stance so these are antibodies that tag
the proteins of interest so here in red
is simply attack that looks for nerve
specific cells and then green isn't a
regular one and you can see how
beautifully expressed it is in these
cell bodies is definitely there it is
also found in peripheral nerves so you
can see here we collected the nerves to
be cross-section them and then we saw
that the regulan one again showing green
is in fact present in the nerves so
these are two really good things to find
first off it meant that the effector was
located where it should be and moreover
it is also found on the blastema and
here are mixing things up a bit
naari Gillan is now in red whereas
beardy you the prolific marker I
mentioned earlier is in green and when
we zoom in on this blastema what we see
is that first of all a lot of these
cells are red and also a lot of these
proliferating cells are co-expressed
with regular ones so many of these cells
are both green and red which indicates
to us that there is at least some sort
of correlation between proliferation and
the regular one we can't say necessarily
but no regular causes proliferation have
to do many more experiments for that but
it is a sort of correlative relationship
and when we go in and actually quantify
how many of these proliferating cells
express in the regular one it's
somewhere it is the majority of the
cells somewhere in the area of 60 to 70
percent now of course we found the
ligand we should also expect to find the
receptor Murphy - we study here B -
because it is the active receptor of the
regulan and in fact here shown and right
you could say that this receptor is very
strongly expressed in the blastema
so that's really it's bound where it's
supposed to be and moreover if we
actually be nerve 8 the limb what we
find is a lack of neuronal 1 and RP 2 so
here on the Left I've shown you
an rb2 stain and at the innervated Lam
and it's it's supposed to be in red you
can see there really isn't much therapy
to be found in this limb well it's also
interesting is all these yellow cells
which you've probably noticed those
cells are not in fact stained for
anything there's simply Auto
fluorescence they show this kind of
yellow or white color and that is simply
cellular debris apoptosis Elle's red
blood cells just a lot of chaos that
occurs after denervation in these limbs
and this is something that we don't
generally see in large quantities and
then when we go through and quantify how
many cells expressed in regular one or
rb2 we do find that as predicted given
the images that you see here the regulan
one and rp2 are down regulated or lost
upon denervation in a quantifiable there
so that's number one
we found the regulan one and we found
its receptor we can check that first
characteristic off our list now the
second one was going to be a lot harder
because to this end we had to Gretzky
regeneration in limbs that were Dean
emitted so we did here was we soaked
these little beads overnight and I
circled them there for you these are
tiny gel like beads that can take up
protein and then release it in a
controlled manner later on so this here
is a control in and this limb was not D
nerve ated it simply received controlled
beads that had PBS in them PBS being a
saline that we used as a control and
these sorts of experiments here is a
limb that was döner baited and then
implanted with PBS soaked beads you can
see that nothing happened as we'd expect
an attenuated limb there was no growth
whatsoever
but when we soaked beads in a regular
one overnight instead we actually saw
the growth of blastemas so what is
happening here is this limb has been
innervated but it's still developing a
blastema because naraku and juan has
been supplemented these little beads
that are releasing it over time in a
manner that we hope in our would in a
brick normal Undine aerated animal and
when we quantify these limbs we were
very excited and happy to find that in
fact these new regulan treated animals
grew quite comparably to the controls
whereas with the deer baited animals
that simply receive PBS those did not
grow as all as you would expect so this
is a
a fairly powerful method of getting
these loans to form blastemas and
actually regenerate it now of course
there's always a question know is it
simply that an irregular one is keeping
the nerves alive and allowing those
nerves to do whatever it is that they do
with a limp so we had to collect those
limbs section them and stain them to
nerve to make sure they were actually
innervated and I've shown here up at the
top left your normal innovative blastema
with those beautiful nerve stain and red
right here are what the deteriorated
limbs looked like you can see there's
very little red there are no nerves
present but there's still a blastema and
that in the regulan one tree of limb
applying to us that yes regular one is
capable of producing a blastema and
proliferative growth even in limbs that
have been debated and do not have any
America really whatsoever and this was
very exciting for us because this was
one of the first instances we had where
a protein proved capable of doing this
in the Mexican X model now this is it
was well it was really exciting I mean
we had a blast even growing even when
there weren't any nerves present but our
goal in humans at least is to grow back
limbs right not to go back little tiny
bumps so we want to see if we could also
get an irregular one to produce digits
later on in the process so to this end
we added B it's we did the same exact
protocol but we did it later on after
the blast team that had formed and if
you do your B at this point you won't
see any growth I'll show you a picture
of that in a moment in a moment but we
saw that when we added the regular one
we did in fact get deformation of digits
so they weren't well formed they weren't
exactly as beautiful as the control
limbs were quite in comparison to the
innovative limbs that only received PBS
they were really quite impressive and
much larger and we can see this when we
quantify the growth as well it plateaued
a little bit over time it seems the
regulan was incapable of really
supporting that much growth late in the
process but those limbs did grow
significantly more than the PBS trade of
limbs did so we can effectively cross
off number two on our check list and say
that yes the regulan one does in fact
rescue regeneration and Dean abated lips
now by comparison this third this third
thing our checklist wasn't quite easy
all we had to do was inhibit an
irregular one to show that it blocks
generation so here again is an
innovative control Hyundai 13 with a
lovely blastema going at the end and
here is a limb that was treated with the
very potent herb b2 inhibitor 2 is the
receptor the inhibitor new printing it
also called TAC 165 and treatment with
this drug completely blocked her
generation
we saw wound healing but we saw
absolutely no formation of the blastema
we saw no prolific growth whatsoever
in fact if you took a look at this limb
without knowing he was treated you what
we think it had been innovated this is
borne out in the quantification of
growth which so shows that there is very
very little growth in both denervated
and drug treated limbs and this tells us
that yes if we inhibit in regula-1
signaling we are able to actually block
regeneration even an otherwise
completely normal animals it also points
out that our dosage in this case was 500
nanomolar which is extremely extremely
dilute this is a very potent drug and it
is nevertheless very capable of blocking
regeneration in these animals now when
we take a look inside these limbs we
don't see anything too surprising again
shown in green is the proliferative
market brdu
the regenerating limb that has nerves
it's beautifully proliferating with lots
and lots appear to your expression but
that DNA sorry that not an innovated
limb that drug treated limb that has
received me prison it is not really
proliferating at all it still has nerves
which you can see there stained in red
but proliferation is almost completely
absent from these lamps they have been
halted in their tracks and they will be
until the drug is removed if you looked
at the trichrome staining at the bottom
you can also see maybe just a little bit
of blue at the tip of that drug treated
limb and that is actually this is a
Mason strike rum stain so that blue is
showing us connective tissue and that is
incredibly unusual in the axolotl
because it indicates sort of the
beginning of scarring these animals do
not scar they're not supposed to scar
epidermal injuries they it's nothing
like humans where we'd form scars quite
readily and so this indicates to us that
blocking ordinary deal in one signaling
is doing quite a lot so these limbs it's
not just blocking regeneration it's also
causing some sort of apparent fibrosis
and perhaps having other as well now not
surprisingly when we went through and
quantified counted the number of green
cells that we saw proliferation was very
very heavily reduced in these new Burton
Ava treated limbs now this was what
happened if we added the drug at day
zero at the same time that we amputated
the limbs if we add the drug later on we
got a bit of a different effect so
here's a control limb
twenty-eight days post amputation we
haven't done anything to it and here is
a limb that was döner baited later on in
the process around day 16 after the
blastema had actually formed and what I
hope you can see there is that this
animal did form a lip it's just a little
tiny baby little tiny digits at the end
and this has been known for pretty a
long time my max a lot of researchers
and it has suggested that the nerve is
primarily involved in the proliferation
of generating limb not in the patterning
of digit formation but we wanted to see
can we get this effect if we add the
trunk at that time instead of debating
and in fact we did so again this is a
bit of an intermediate limb between the
D Nevada and the innervated ones but we
did see the formation of these little
baby digits which indicate to us that
the more attentive treatment the Irby to
inhibition was blocking proliferation
but not the later stages of the
generation and we can see this
proliferative block if we take a look at
the quantification of the growth where
over time those drug treated lambs
simply plateaued they got a little bit
bigger than the D Nevada bones but they
did still just completely stop for
generating over time and that would
fulfill our third requirement so simply
to go over them again
we found that New England one is in the
correct role nerves in the dorsal root
ganglia in the bus team exactly where
you'd expect it to be along with its
receptor we found that regeneration
could be rescued and T related animals
if we add it in regulan and we found
that inhibition of new regular blocked
regeneration and otherwise normal
animals which is all very exciting
because it showed to us that the regulan
one has the characteristics
characteristics that you would expect
from an essential
factor now we can ask ourselves isn't a
revealing one the missing link between
nerves and regeneration is that what the
nerves are supplying that promotes
growth of the regenerating limb now I
don't want to make it sound like the
regular one is the only factor that is
involved in regeneration there's
certainly a constellation of factors out
there and many of its studied over the
years these include Jeff's new interior
gradient north growth factor transferrin
insulin it's a very very long list and
it's believed that of course they're all
interacting in some way we don't yet
know how in a regular one interacts with
these other factors or which factors are
upstream or downstream of which but we
are excited about in regulan because we
did find it in the nerves and we believe
it is a highly upstream signal coming
from the nerves and signaling right into
the blastema itself and in future
studies we hope to explore this function
of deregulate how it does what it does
and whether or not this function extends
across other organs and systems in the
axolotl now I love this story
this was my doctoral work I put a lot
into it and I'm very fond of it but as
much as I do love it in the regulan
itself didn't quite feel like the whole
story and I want to show you why it is
that I think that so the denotative limb
is a mess to put it simply there's just
a lot going on and a lot of it looks
like cellular chaos right so I've showed
you this photo earlier which has a lot
of osteoclasts a lot of inflammatory
cells here's another image of a teen
invaded limb that's showing again
everything in yellow is just cellular
debris and this one looks like a mess as
well it doesn't look like a limb or you
simply took away a positive
proliferative factor it looks like
something else is going on here that's
really messing up the regenerative
process and why might this be well it
could be because when you AMPA when you
d negate a limb again you go in and
simply cut the nerves at the brachial
plexus you're not removing the nerves
from the limb itself and a nerve that's
been cut is a damaged nerve damage nerve
is not very happy
in fact nerves that have been oxidized
and nervous which have been damaged
release a lot of different signals that
Lisa's has been found in in mice and
rats
relief signals which bring in
inflammatory cells and
sorts of other effects so a döner vated
nerve is not inert its have it's
exerting some sort of other possibly
inflammatory effects on the limb that
led us to ask what happens when we
debate are we causing a sort of
inflammatory environment that's going to
block regeneration now how much of this
contributes to the bet to this
phenomenon nerve dependence and so we
have to look at this from a slightly
different angle now I want to show you a
new model or this is amol has been
around for a while but this is new for
the presentation and it's a really fun
kind of interesting one we couldn't look
at a mutation to start because
amputation is a really complex process
right you're cutting through nerve
you're cutting through muscle and bone
and all sorts of different tissues we
just want to look at what happens when
you cut a nerve so we use this model
called the accessory limb or accessory
blastema model where you make a little
tiny incision on the animal skin so you
make a little wound just right here and
then you grab a peripheral nerve so you
cut it a little bit further down from
that wound and he redirect it so that
it's sitting at the wound site so what
you end up having is this window in the
epidermis as well as this cut end of a
nerve kind of just hanging out in that
wound and what happens is you actually
get the formation of a bump and that
bump is pretty much identical to a
blastema so down on the bottom there
those are in situ s that look for
blastema markers and these bumps produce
pretty much all the same markers as a
blastema does so if this shows us is
that all you need to form a blastema is
a wound really simple one and the cut
end of the nerve and we use this to our
advantage to study whether or not nerves
have inhibitory signals as well so here
are a couple of other diagrams of this
model you can see that we deviate that
in army kind of you grab it and move it
forms a blastema here's yet another
example of how this works and here's the
kind of crazy thing that we did to test
whether or not damaged nerves are
capable of inhibiting regeneration as
opposed to simply removing a
proliferative signal which is what we've
always thought of denervation it's doing
so we did the accessory blastema study
as we normally do we made a wound we
deviated a nerve and then we
a nerve bundle from another animal in
this case a GFP or a green fluorescent
protein expressing animal and in the
process of removing that nerve we
debated it right you cut it off from its
cell bodies we then implanted this nerve
bundle at the wound site of the animal
which had undergone the surgery so you
can see there fluorescing in green that
is a different bundle of nerves one
which has been debated and effectively
damaged we placed it right next to that
host nerve that should be producing lots
of nice proliferative factors and
causing this beautiful blastema growth
and we saw that the GFP the fluorescence
did not go down over time which actually
implies to us that those nerves that
those damaged nerves are still alive in
some way and when we sectioned these
limbs later on around day 15 we did see
strong expression of GFP indicating yes
those cells are still alive they're
still doing something maybe now we
wanted to see where they infect
inhibiting the formation of this
blastema
so here's a control experiment very very
reliable production of these blastema
bumps that we had 16 of 21 of the
surgeries that we did but if we added
this additional damaged nerve bundle we
only saw a bump forming in two of 12
cases so in fact when we added this sort
of competitive damaged nerve to the
normal site we were able to completely
block regeneration and bulk formation
and if we take a look inside those limbs
we see a lot of cellular chaos they say
that the nerve has been deviated
password should be we see aberrant
collagen deposition down there in blue
and we see a limb but is not very happy
and not like who need to start
regenerating for me a blastema any time
soon now it could simply be but you know
we're inducing this mechanical sort of
inhibition because we're doing it an
experiment where we're stuffing a lot of
tissue with a lip so check for this we
decellularized those nerve implants by
putting them in liquid nitrogen and also
heating them up so freeze thaw freeze
thaw this got rid of the GFP so it
effectively killed off the cells but the
extracellular matrix of the structure of
the tissue graft remained intact and you
can see that in the bottom photo here in
the mesas trichrome stay
when we freeze thought our tissues in
this way we did not see any inhibition
of growth in fact we saw pretty normal
blastema growth altogether and this
indicates to us and it wasn't the
surgery that was inhibiting the growth
of these bumps it wasn't simply adding
any sort of mechanical aspect of it
this was in fact the result of something
active happening with these living cells
so perhaps these cells are secreting
something that is competing with other
positive signals at the wound site and
preventing regeneration as we know it
now it could also be you might be
thinking yourself yeah they're
introducing foreign tissue into a limb
of course it's going to cause problems
and I should note that X levels are
incredibly receptive to graphs they
really don't reject them not just from
other animals but in fact from other
species of animals so there have been
experiments looking at graphs with
tissue frog and fish tissue and the X
levels really don't reject those but we
did want to make sure that this was not
necessarily something that happened with
all tissues right so we implanted muscle
into the site as instead and we saw that
muscle implantation did not block
blastema formation factor we saw a very
lovely blastemas when we implanted this
foreign muscle tissue so it clearly
isn't simply the result of other living
tissue being present the wound site it's
something that is at least moderately
nerve specific now as I've said before
of course we our goal is not to grow
bumps on human arms our goal is to grow
back human arms so we made sure to test
whether or not this phenomenon was
observed in regenerating ones as well
and so to that end we simply took
peripheral nerve bundles like we did for
the previous experiment and cut off the
limb and added those nerve bundles
either one or two right at the
amputation site on day zero and we did
find that regeneration was slowed down
and in some cases quite quite messed up
which I'll show you in a moment when we
added these additional nerve bundles so
with two nerve implants shown on the
graph here we saw a very significant
decrease in growth with one implant we
saw somewhat significant but it wasn't
nearly as striking and of course we did
the control surgeries as well where we
freeze thought those implants and so we
still had the
structure of the nerve present but the
nerves themselves were not alive and
these sham or freeze-thaw surgeries were
completely almost completely identical
to the controls which did not receive
implants as well at all
so what we can say here is once again
yes there's some sort of active some
sort of activity coming from these
damaged nerves that is in some way
interfering with normal or generation
and it really does interfere I'm going
to show you here so these are what the
limbs that received to nerve implants
look like remember they were seeping
damaged nerves that are giving off
something we're not sure what and the
sort of aberrations and abnormalities
that we saw in these limbs they were
incredibly buried and really pretty
bizarre and fun to look at and these
ranged all the way from blastema that
was arrested very early on and so they
never developed two digits in some cases
we saw no digits or bifurcation of the
arm and even when digits formed they
were often either missing one or two or
the digits to themselves for quite
abnormal a shortens which we can see in
this last image here now when we took a
look inside these limbs without seeing
blue staining you can see on the right
there that there's a lot there's a lot
that's wrong in this limb it only has
two digits it has looks like maybe a car
going off into space as opposed to our
control and our sham surgery limbs which
are beautiful fully formed and look
almost identical so again there's
something happening here when we
introduce a damaged nerve into the
environment we are in some way competing
with the nerves that should be producing
something alliterative and I'll show you
how this all wraps up together in just a
moment now we are able to score these
limbs so what we can do is go in and
actually say whether or not these limbs
fully regenerated and kind of classify
them based on what we see so here in
green we have limbs that were ranked or
scored as a three that simply means that
they were generated fully and perfectly
that's what you want to see they look
just like the original limb the yellow
or score two is a limb that was highly
abnormal in its morphology but they
produce some sort of digit and the score
number one that's shown in red is a limb
that simply didn't grow at all maybe
from a little tiny blastema but it never
just past that and what I hope you can
see in this figure here is that the Dean
of hidden limbs mostly just didn't grow
but the limbs that receive damaged nerve
implants the ones that we did that
you're grafting surgery into those no
those limbs ended up looking really
really bizarre they had a lot of
abnormalities some of them didn't grow
some of them grew perfectly but as a
whole the majority of them showed some
sort of strange in-between aberrations
and we're working now to determine what
are these factors which are produced by
these nerves and eventually results
means aberrations and how does it
interact with the regular one is it in
any way involved in this process so the
conclusions that we've come to so far or
that limb Peter Batian is a little bit
more complex than it might appear at
first so we believe that there are sort
of two major aspects to limit
innervation that combine in order to
prevent regeneration of the salamander
limb so first of all when your Dean
abate and you go in and cut those nerves
at the brachial plexus you are losing
proliferative factors that are released
at the wound site so for example the
regular one we know that Naraku and one
goes down after dinner vation you know
it is able to truly act as it should and
so we can say that half of denervation
involves the removal of a positive
proliferative signal we're preventing
that signal from traveling from the cell
bodies down the nerves and from being
released at the website but we can also
now say that there's a second aspect a
little bit less appreciated perhaps less
studied to limbed innervation that also
prevents her generation and that is this
sort of introduction of a negative or
inflammatory signal from those nerves
themselves which have been innovated so
we can say here is that innervation
produces a lot of very damaged nerves
that are giving off some sort of factor
that is antiproliferative potentially or
they could potentially be bringing in
leukocytes and white blood cells to
prevent regeneration in other ways and
this is something that we're still
working to determine is it a direct
inhibition from some factor released by
damaged nerves or is it that they are
causing inflammation but then in its own
way prevents regeneration but we can
best kind of summarize all of this by
saying that the innervation of the
axolotl limb prevents regeneration in
two ways they remove
a proliferative signal a positive signal
and it adds an inhibitory perhaps
inflammatory signal and our dream is to
one day find the ways in which these two
halves of the innovation interact with
each other and perhaps unite them to get
a whole complete picture of what happens
after denervation and how regeneration
is affected by it
now other areas that we're excited to
explore first of all we'd really love to
see how the regulan one affects other
organs and tissues in the ex well so
these are just a couple of photos
they're very very rare and rough but
here you have a heart on the left that's
simply a developing axolotl heart and on
the right is a heart that's been
injected with an irregular one and you
can see that proliferation has gone up
quite considerably in this heart so we'd
really like to explore whether or not in
regula-1 is involved in the regeneration
of the axolotl hearts as axles do have
the ability to recover from cryo injury
and transection of the vegetables in
arguing one is also being studied quite
extensively and mammals for its heart
protective a potentially regenerative
ability there's some very exciting
recent studies showing that it may in
fact be capable of at least inducing
some sort of cardio protective effect in
mammals we're excited to explore this in
the salamander as well and also because
this is such a flexible and fascinating
and highly really quite variable model
that we can do a lot of fun experiments
on we'd also like to use it to look at
other aspects that maybe haven't really
been thought of previously in terms of
regeneration so for example when you cut
off a limb pretty proximal to the animal
you are that that animal has to
regenerate a joint and this provides us
with a really great model for looking at
joint morphogenesis in formation because
studying joint morphogenesis and
developing animal is often quite
difficult they're usually very small and
protected by their by it by a uterus so
what we can actually do here is amputate
an axolotl limb and then study how this
joint forms as it is regenerating we can
do all sorts of really fun manipulations
to that regenerating whim to see how
does immobilizing the limb affect joint
formation how does reversing flexion of
the land change joy information
and this is something that we'll be
working on going forward in my
postdoctoral work here I know at Eastern
University very excited to see where it
takes us then with that I'd like to
thank all these people list on the slide
members of the Monahan lab the whited
lab our collaborators the shuffle buying
lab which I'm now doing postdoctoral
work in our funding sources and of
course all of you for watching today I
really appreciate that you did thank you
so much and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you dr. Johanna parkas for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is can Axl
out axolotls die of old age and do they
get cancer okay so axolotls you might
think that because they're so amazingly
regenerative but they might be capable
of living forever perhaps but in fact
they do die of old age now they live a
little bit longer than you might expect
from a salamander about 20 years or so
but they do infect senesce over time so
they grow older and they do eventually
die for old age
now one thing that's really amazing
about salamanders is they retain their
regenerative and their reproductive
abilities throughout adulthood which is
something that sets them apart from many
other vertebrates in terms of cancer
this is another area of explore research
that's just really fascinating and
there's a lot of potential in despite
the fact that many of the pathways the
genes and proteins they utilize are
oncogenic so that for example RB 2 which
I talked about is highly implicated in
some cancers they are highly cancer
resistant animals so axolotls do
sometimes form neoplasms and a very
small percentage of animals but as far
as metastatic cancer goes it's very very
I can't say for sure that they're immune
to it but it is extremely rare to the
point that it hasn't really been
characterized in these animals and
moreover attempts to actually induce
metastatic cancer Naxals have not to
this point succeeded so going forward
one major question is how is it that
they don't seem to get cancer at the
rates that we do and how are they able
to control these pollutants oncogenic
pathways
so tightly such that they don't
accidentally get a tumor when they are
regenerating come in thank you for that
answer our next question is when an
axolotl limb grow back if you amputate
it more than once so you might wonder
now is the exponent limb capable of
actually just continually regenerating
and in fact it is it's a really
remarkable feature of the axolotl
salamander that you can amputate a limb
and you can amputate it once it's grown
back and the limb that you'll see is
pretty functionally identical to the
very first limb even then this can be
repeated over and over and over again
without any loss of regenerative
fidelity in fact some recent research
has shown that these repeated amputation
limbs are in fact really really close to
the original now there is one exception
to this which is if you amputate a limb
bud very early on so for example a
blastema that forms if you can't you
take that repeatedly it seems that
somehow the pool of regenerating cells
is depleted or exhausted in some way and
you get just a little tiny baby mm
instead of a fully functional
regenerated limb so we can say that it
is capable of regenerating over and over
if you cut the fully regenerated limb
but we still don't exactly know how
similar the first limb is or how similar
the original limb is to be say 50th
regenerated one we do know that it looks
and functions the same but in terms of
what's actually found inside of it
that's still an area of study that is
being looked at
okay it looks like we have time for one
more question
do you Newman share many genes with
axolotls is naraku killin one found in
human so yeah that's a great question
because I've talked a lot about in the
regulan one and it's pathways and its
abilities in the salamander but what it
really matter if humans do not in fact
Express this gene but the good news is
that no regulan one is not just found in
humans it's found in a huge variety of
animals down to very very early
primitive invertebrates
so no regulan one is very well conserved
we'll stay across that lajjun ii and
really it's the abilities of the regular
one that are that are simply different
from animal to animal so it is possible
that someday we'll be able to utilize in
a regular and in some way in humans to
have protective effects potentially to
help limbs back but again we always have
to worry about the fact that it can't
its receptor can't be oncogenic now
humans and excells do have a surprising
number of conservation between their
genomes EXA levels have a much larger
genome same number of genes but about 20
times the size is their genome because
they have so much what looks to be junk
DNA and while there are many salamanders
specific genes and of course very
closely related they are still as I said
vertebrates that are sort of the closest
to us that are capable of this complex
tissue degeneration and in looking at
how they're able to regenerate and which
pathways and genes they utilize we can
hopefully see how humans might be able
to do the same as well and we're
comforted by the fact that many of these
major genes such as Mary Gillen one are
in fact shared between humans and
salamanders
I would like to once again thank dr.
Johanna markets for her presentation I
would also like to thank lab boots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December of 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcements with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye